kylie had her little boy it was
announced the other day i had to be very
you know i got to be very quiet i got to
be very sensitive and be very careful
when i talk about the family but they're
great connie's doing great everybody's
doing good
caitlyn jenner opens up about her
daughter kylie jenner welcoming baby
number two with travis scott things are
going well the 72 year old former
olympian appeared on good morning
britain on wednesday and revealed she's
already met her new grandson who was
born on february 2nd
have you met your 19th grandchild yet
kylie's new baby yes i have the family
is growing
and she wasn't kidding it's been the
most amazing year kylie and travis's new
little bundle of joy marks the 19th
grandchild for caitlyn who has six
children of her own this has been
wonderful
and grandbaby number 20 is due any day
now my son bert and his wife
uh they're doing a month with a little
girl
so
i'm going for number 20 here in nevada
in about a month i love it i can never
keep all the birthdays right it's all on
computer
of course kylie and travis announced the
arrival of their baby boy whose name
they have yet to reveal on sunday
posting this sweet black and white snap
that's their four-year-old daughter
stormy holding on to her newborn
siblings tiny hand the caption the
baby's b-day 2-22
alongside a blue heart emoji i'm excited
about it as for the name fans are
speculating it may be valentine or angel
pointing out that valentine's day is
coming up and she dropped a new kylie
cosmetics valentine's day collection on
february 4th i love it then there's
kylie's sister kim kardashian who slid
into the comments with an angel emoji
the 24 year old's bff stasi swooped in
with an angel baby her makeup artist
ariel tejada wrote can't wait to meet
the little angel while her momager kris
jenner added simply angel pie
oh my gosh such a gift back in september
kylie confirmed the happy news that they
were expecting posting this sweet video
of the couple's positive pregnancy test
their visit to the doctor's office and
the sweet moment the entrepreneur broke
the news to her mom what do you have for
lovie
oh what is this
[Music]
and in a trailer for the kardashians new
hulu series kylie's baby bump is on full
display
fans are hoping to see more of her
pregnancy journey and the little one
when the show premieres on april 14th
but for now a source tells e.t kylie and
travis are loving life with their second
child i'm having so much fun quote kylie
and travis are over the moon since the
arrival of their baby boy they have
wanted to grow their family and give
stormy a sibling for a while and they
couldn't be happier
[Music]